-So happy to have you here.
Congrats.
This is really an accomplishment
for the first time
you directed and wrote a film.
It's a beautiful film.
-Thanks.
Thanks for having me.
-Were you --
At what point of being an actor
did you think to yourself, "Oh,
I want to direct one of these,"
or "I want to
write one of these?"
-I have a very odd life,
because I started off
wanting to be a writer/director
my whole life,
and then I kind of
accidentally fell into
this amazing
16-year acting career,
which has been
an insane journey
and is an insane journey,
as well.
But it took me a long time
to figure out --
I hold the position of director
in such high regard
that I didn't want
to just be some actor
goofing off trying to do it.
It's something
that matters to me,
something that's
important to me,
and so I took four years,
and I waited till I had a story
that rally
meant something to me.
-It's called "Mid90s."
It's about a group of kids
in the mid '90s.
They're skateboarders.
That is the culture.
I have to assume that you were
pulling for something
from your own life
because of the amount
of specificity to this world.
Like, this had
to have been something
that you experienced
to some degree.
-Yeah, I mean, I was
a horrifically
terrible skateboarder.
I -- I --
[ Laughter ]
I would film, 'cause I liked
to tell people what to do,
and I wanted to be a director.
So it was the perfect role
in that group of friends.
And I was unathletic, so...
[ Laughter ]
But, you know,
the story's about --
It's not a biopic,
but it's personal in the sense
that I relate to being 13,
I relate to being lonely,
and I relate to something
giving you a community
outside of your home
and a group of friends
and something
to fall in love with.
And, ultimately,
this movie is just about
a group of kids at a time
when it's you and your friends
versus the world
and your family is less
important than your friends.
-I've heard you refer to it
as an animal-kingdom movie.
And I'm assuming that refers
to just the pecking order
of kids at that age and how some
are more dominant than others.
-Yeah, well, the kid's like 13,
and then there's another kid
who's like 14 who kind of is
the first one that talks to him,
and then there's kids
up to like 18, 19.
So he's kind of figuring out
how to play --
move around the chessboard
and figure out how to fit in
and then move up.
And I don't know.
It's just -- I've related --
I kind of feel like all of
the characters in some ways,
because I feel like,
when you're young,
in the '90s especially --
I don't know
if you relate to this.
A big part
of the movie is, like,
the corniest thing you could do
is try or care about anything.
And that's
a big part of the movie
is that none of them care,
and it's kind of showing off
how little they care.
I mean, they're pretty much
beautiful morons
and, essentially,
like my friends and I were.
You know?
Which is like,
they make so many mistakes,
they speak in ugly vernacular,
there's toxic masculinity,
homophobia,
things that are true
to the time
and truly hard to watch
but I felt would be more
offensive to be revisionist
and to change the way it was
than to hold a mirror
up to how ugly it was.
So these kids do things,
they endanger each other's live,
but at the same time,
they deeply love each other.
So nothing's
really black-and-white,
and the movie's
not black-and-white,
and I hope, if I'm lucky enough
to get to do this again,
to always create
complex characters
that are challenging what our
definitions of good and bad are.
-One thing that's amazing is,
no matter how good
a script you wrote
or how well you directed it,
obviously, it was
very reliant on the cast,
and you went outside of just
natural professional actors,
and you cast
a lot of skateboarders
to be the actors in this film.
-Yeah, and I actually
wanted to finish my point,
because I went astray
for one moment,
which is just --
And that's totally on me,
by the way.
-No, no.
-Not on you.
But the idea is that
the corniest thing you could do
was to care.
-Yeah.
-And there's a kid
named Ray in the movie,
a character named Ray,
who's played beautifully
by one of the first-time actors,
Na-kel Smith.
And he tells this kid,
in a way that's not corny,
and subtly, basically,
he does care
and he's trying at life.
And I found,
whether I was a young kid
trying to fit into a group
or the older kid
trying to make
someone else
kind of care a little bit,
when someone older takes the
moment to show you something
in a non-corny, sweaty way,
it sticks with you
for the rest of your life.
-Yeah.
-You know?
And it's really
a very moving story
even if, at times,
it's hard to watch,
and it's funny,
and it's crazy.
-It's really funny.
And I can't believe
that they weren't actors.
I mean, like --
And you tell --
By the way, I know --
-They are now.
-Yeah.
-I know actors, and once
they started skateboarding,
I'm like, "Oh, that's not actors
who learned how to skateboard.
This is definitely
the other way around."
-So, I did, basically,
everything to make
this incredibly difficult
for myself.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-My lead was 11 years old.
You're not supposed
to work with children.
-Who's fantastic.
-Sunny Suljic, he's brilliant.
The rest of the cast,
besides his family,
played by Katherine Waterston
and Lucas Hedges,
both brilliant actors,
are first-time actors,
and they're all
real skateboarders.
A lot of them are professionals,
you know, or semiprofessional,
and, you know, skateboarding,
which is always constantly
butchered in film.
So, I chose a subculture that
doesn't want to be spoken about
and doesn't want the kid
from "Superbad"
making a movie about them.
[ Laughter ]
I chose to work with children,
which are --
Notoriously, you're not supposed
work with children or animals.
And I also decided
to take on the duty
of elegantly framing hip-hop,
which is another subculture
often butchered on film
that doesn't want
the kid from "Superbad"
making a movie about it,
about how this music
is the emotional backbone
of my and a lot
of people's childhood
and how A Tribe Called Quest
is, to me,
what John Lennon
is to my parents.
-Yeah.
-Right?
And I guess
I'm comfortable in discomfort
and comfortable
with a lot of challenges
because it turned out to be
the most beautiful, challenging,
emotional, incredible
experience of my life.
And I am genuinely --
I have to come on here
and sell [bleep]
whether I like it or not.
[ Laughter ]
I'm being dead serious.
I could be on here next time,
like, telling you something...
-Wait! Wait a second!
You've lied to me?!
-I love seeing you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I love seeing you.
And I love seeing you,
and I love seeing you,
and I love seeing all of you,
and sometimes I have to be
on here on some bull [bleep]
and, like,
this movie is my heart.
I spent four years making it.
I care about it.
I love it, and I promise you,
if you go see it,
you will be moved and laugh
and enjoy yourself.
So, thank you.
Go see it.